galina du rova a vécu toute sa vie dans
cet immeuble voilà ce qu'il en reste
désormais dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi la russie a une nouvelle fois
lourdement bombardé ce quartier
résidentiel de torres qu faisant
plusieurs morts galina a eu très peur
pour sa vie
il y a eu de violentes explosions dans
tout le quartier
puis tout est redevenu calme et j'ai
commencé à fermer les yeux soudain une
compet de fumée noire et de feu s'est
abattu sur ma fenêtre d'un seul coup
j'ai été soumis des scènes de
destructions visibles également en
dehors du dombass où le kremlin
concentre ses forces
exemple à rare qu'yves la deuxième ville
du pays où tirs de roquettes et missiles
rythment le quotidien des habitants
depuis le début de la guerre
nouvelle frappe ce lundi matin
blessé à la tête cet habitant est soigné
à lattes juste à côté de chez elle
des bombardements russes également
signalés dans la matinée à micola yves
et dans la région de dnipropetrovsk
agnico paul où le port un hôpital et
deux usines ont été endommagés sur le
plan diplomatique les ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne étudie depuis ce lundi matin
un durcissement des sanctions contre
moscou sanction qui laisse pertes ils
vont un jour contraindre vladimir
poutine à mettre un terme à la guerre en
ukraine